[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 ball chest classic I am your host
Caleb Denby and today Boros is back I'm
joined once again by the wonderful
Grandmaster Dennis Boros who will be
sticking it through to the end of this
tournament now promises promises
yes so it's quite a weekend that you
missed Dennis what happens you're still
keeping an eye on the games but that's
on a quick two-day vacation but I was
watching some of the games yeah
well we actually had some surprises go
on yesterday so why don't we take a look
at the standings and see where it lies
here's Group a ray Robson actually
surprisingly won his game yesterday a
limit of two from my perspective he's 2
out of 2 from your perspective fair
enough he actually was in a fairly equal
position against Alexander Letterman but
then the players kind of mix things up a
little bit white give up some pawns on
the Queen side black or the other way
round black on the Queen side white on
the Kings side and Ray managed to
convert to a full point putting him in
clear first going into today she's
amazing because he did actually win on
the first day when Patrick was here yeah
he beats Ilyas myrin but that game was
very impressive
right yeah ray playing some excellent
chess chasing him is your van forest as
well as a myriad of players who are on
50 or yet 50 percent in lunderman vara
Cobian Dhirubhai lee and dario schrutes
and cron Tinnell Quyen definitely a lot
of contenders in the egg group and over
in the B group here's our current
situation yessir Quesada Perez was the
other surprise win yesterday he also had
a fairly equal position and then managed
to check me at the black King with some
fancy night maneuvers so congratulations
to him he is now the B group sole leader
passing up
Jack's team buyuk who was off to a
roaring start with three out of three in
this event
but has since slowed down also chasing
is Viktor Michalowski and Denis a CAD
rich who are both on three out of five
and with that that's where we currently
stand let's take a look at the
tournament format that these players are
playing in of course there are 210
player round robins that's that a group
and b group that we just took a look at
the time control for this event is 90
minutes for the first 40 moves with 30
minutes added on after move 40 for the
remainder of the game there is also a
30-second increment from move 1 there is
also a draw rule in effect the players
are not allowed to offer each other a
draw until black makes his thirtieth
move as always we'd like to thank you
for joining us here on our live coverage
you're welcome to get involved in the
YouTube chat if you have any questions
for us please let us know I've got some
pretty tough questions in there I don't
think I can prove any math theorems I do
know the name of the tournament it's the
fall chess classic is in deep and
Grandmaster Danish Boros is of course
from Hungary yes so that's the answer to
your current questions if you come up
with any chess questions for us we'll be
happy to answer those as well yeah
you're also welcome to follow the games
for yourself on us chess champs calm
that's where all the action is being
broadcast and lastly if you want to get
involved on Twitter you can use the
hashtag fall chess classic hashtag fall
chess classic well remember hash tag
full chess classic that's the one name
of the tournament all right well why
don't we just get right into it and
let's take a look at the pairings in
Group A Alexander Linderman squares off
against Wasif Dhirubhai Lee front
malcolm ian is paired against ilya
smearin olexander bortnik takes on Doris
routes Alex if etaf is actually already
drawn his game with Jordan one forest
so that tournament number two player
Jordan von forest in the a group has
already drawn giving ray Robson the
chance to pull further ahead in our key
matchup of the day he is of course
taking on Vera Cobian who is on 50%
right now definitely still in the mix to
catch up and even possibly win this
tournament
yes the big American derby the big
American derby the the to us players
square off in the a group here here we
see the players and it's actually quite
an interesting position Oh what's going
on here
well what's actually even more
interesting and exciting about this is
that they actually played this line
before Wow
if the US Championships yeah and it was
a topsy-turvy game which was complicated
Akopian had chances sacrifice the piece
and it was a mess because black got lots
of pawns but in the end somehow Ray
Robson found a way to break through even
though the position was around balanced
Wow
he managed to win it in the end game so
it was a very dramatic game it's very
interesting that they decided to
actually repeat it yeah of course these
players have played each other numerous
times I think the record is something
like four wins for Ray eight draws in in
four wins for for a cobia those very
well balanced very well balanced and the
last time they faced was actually
earlier this year in new US
Championships so it's interesting
usually just if I come back here usually
now everybody plays Bishop e7 originally
a six and B five was the main line and I
think you once you've recently started
playing 92 so everybody started playing
92 them so yeah not a bad player to a
copy you want to kiss someone to copy so
Queen b6 will stay this is an old line
white can actually give up a pawn take
rook here and if I'm correct Bishop b5
and the plan is to castle f5 and hope
for the best right objectively I'm not
sure if this is great for white but it
is compensation and play for it but Ray
decided to go for not a for Queen eight
five c3 this is also an old line c4 was
originally played before cuz otherwise
take your knife and be five this this
horsey is in big danger here right so
here be four must be played and the old
main line is takes takes Bishop b4 and
King f2 and in these positions black has
these pawns that he's trying to push and
he has some chances because this Knight
is clumsy here on a4 but objectively
they according to theory this is
advantageous for white yeah
gotta love the side with the extra piece
yes not almost enough everybody loves
the extra piece but what was playing the
game now so b6 was played the idea being
Bishop a6 so Cobian tries to get rid of
this terrible Bishop of course the
French bishop the French Bishop but
Bishop d2 is a big big move here if
Bishop a6 there are some c4 stuff going
on and that would be troublesome yeah
Queens looking a little bit stuck over
there yeah so a COPI on place c4 which
in general is not a great move for black
black needs to have some counter play in
the center to actually have some play
for himself after c4 wide it gets free
play on the Kings side now it's
obviously not that easy but in theory
that was thought here so b4 bus blade
you can't really take oh you can't
really take because the screen is still
trapped and b4 is kind of strong yeah
you need that pawn on c4 to make sure
that the the bishop can never really
access the Queen yeah on the other hand
it's true that the Kobe on played to c4
but this night on a4 is totally out of
place right and so everyone who just new
to this position and would like to put
the night on b2 it's good to remember
that Queen a3 is a typical very strong
move for black it really eyes that weak
c3 pawn is yes this pawn would get
really weak and from here on blacks plan
would be very easy you just go be 585
and just roll over are white
yeah he's really putting some pressure
on the uncomfortable points in White's
position here but as I told you the
viewer before this is their second game
in this line so you can guess that
Robson knows what he's doing
so he didn't play not be too there for
Bishop e7 castle castle Queen c2 so
there's a bit of a waiting game going on
if black would play b5 white would like
to pose and I don't see five so black is
waiting for white to move the knight
first right so plays at five
the idea being he doesn't want to see f5
coming anytime soon if you exchange it
like the position does open up for the
better for black yeah the the bishop now
has kind of a path to uh to freedom
through d7 and he ate and eventually
maybe to Jesus this is not just a stone
ball version of escaping it's also
typical French way of escaping right so
night b2 was played and now of Kobe I
took that took his chance to play b5 a
496 and probably Knight b6 was not good
because it loses time yeah white would
love to keep things kind of locked in
the Queen City I imagine because the
Kings side is really where White's
trying to push so Knight b6 kind of begs
wait to play this move a5 yes
which permanently shuts down the pawn
structure on the Queen side and kind of
gives them a free hand I think to expand
on the Kings side yeah and the main
issue is it's easy to play this with
white yeah and you don't have much space
with black so probably Queen b7 would
have been better not that white can't
play a 5 but at least like an already
try maneuvering the night over to g6
exactly while after this moves these
moves black will need to waste
additional time yeah I mean black / 2
moves were Knight b6 in the knight back
to d7 yes obviously doesn't make any
sense
in these close type of positions it's
okay to waste time but if it ever opens
up you'll regret not you regret not
being
enough right so 91 bouquet of 7 and 9 g5
was very nice so it's not that might
once the bishop on e7 but he wants to
order them open F files
he wants the open F file and the
potential to maneuver this Knight to f4
and also this bishop is kind of dumb as
even if it reaches g6 it will just stare
at the wall at best
yeah just easy maneuvers now for yes
tonight these 7 h4 kind of signaling for
black that if you ever think about
putting your knight there I'm gonna
chase you away exactly
so Bishop b7 Knight f2 here comes the
night
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo Cree's
c6 Knight h3 a six-night f4 and it's
funny computers suggest the best move
here but I think this is the move that
I'd play as well ok is that move h5 each
Drive it's black to move black to move
okay well then probably not age 5 yeah
probably that you would play probably 9
g6 yeah I would also consider Knight f8
trying to take on g6 more favorably but
then maybe I think h5 from white might
have been - yeah yeah yeah
Knight that fit you played exactly like
a COPI on well actually we do have a
very important result in the B group
Alexander fear has won his game against
mihailovski and that was actually a
king's gambit yes a very exciting game
we'll definitely have to take a look at
that yes definitely
so now g6 I would consider meaning I
really want to get rid of your night
yeah
don't care whatever it takes I'll do it
right not that takes H takes H 5 is not
better for right but I'd still consider
this move ok so 9 f8 h v g6 rook F 2 and
V currently in this position actually
some moves were played already bishop c8
the bishop went all over the place but
the problem is that you can just
teleport this rook to G
seven and even that I take you yeah
that's that's tough and of course white
always he's the one with the power to
decide when he should open up the
decision so everything going going well
for Ray
so usually Alekhine's gun is on the
cards whenever you get these close
positions you will see all the
grandmasters get there
alright let's say all the bishops away
and then just get the Alekhine's gun yes
coming in the future
very interesting position and looking
quite well for Ray yeah
although Kanaka will be on hold possibly
it's not impossible to hold this
position but black can get brutally made
it if he's not super alert right well
complex positions over in the a group
especially with Ray but we do have a
couple of results already in the B group
so why don't we take a look at the
pairings and then we can see yeah
actually a couple huge results have
already happened so Steven Zurich is
paired against Amon Hamilton today Jack
Stein buyuk has actually already been
defeated by the one a romhack Obion who
were actually going to hopefully get in
for an interview quite shortly
a veteran gorian is paired against
Dennis Cade rich Manuel Petrosyan has
actually drawn his game against the a
circus out of Perez who is leading this
event currently and then of course we
just saw actually in our key matchup of
the day between Alexander fear and
Victor mihailovski
Alexander fear has actually just managed
to win that that game some zany opening
right this is some crazy stuff so I'll
turn it over to you Denish to introduce
this game between Ashton booyaka and Ho
Cobian well we get a co bein in the
studio so another benoni who would have
thought you haven't seen that for a
while so g3c 5v5 obviously we've seen
Knight f3 been played but d5 is the
standard mainline takes takes d6 Bishop
g2 b5 and probably Stamboul iakh miss
played it because I guess Knight c3 is
an important move here stopping b5
another Bishop g2 b5 looks fairly
comfortable for
as usually it takes a lot of time for
black to get that move in a four and
ninety two we should basics this looks
like a very pleasant position and
actually we have a Cobb young with us
congratulations thank you nice win so
what happened in the opening did he miss
play it with Bishop g2 yeah I think so I
think you have to start with 93 mm-hmm
but even after Bishop g2 I don't think
that it's so bad but I mean after B
Pfeiffer I think it's already equal yeah
because you have this firm advantage on
the Queen side also this Bishop is much
better than C if C 4 square is not weak
so it's perfect position for black yeah
so what were your thoughts here because
I'm sure you were surprised to see this
position if you had this as home
preparation I will be really impressed
yeah no I just calculate III and Knight
h3 and neither free is not working so I
thought okay III I have to do something
very fast and I thought okay let's go 94
trade these bishops then 95 and now I
think like it's much better just yeah
like I guess this Bishop is very useful
in general defending the d5 pawn but
right yeah yeah it actually looks wrong
it actually does nothing it's a night
eat night of 395 actually here instead
of night of free I calculate 92 the idea
was in night de5 take 95 Queen e5 and
play castle mm-hmm
but I think here I have 9 h - yes and if
King is - okay Quinn age 5 yep and you
collect everything yeah
and last but not least these pawns are
most yeah it should be completely lost
yeah it's winning go back so Knight f3
95 takes takes castle Queen f6 okay he
can't take on e5 because of peach f1 97
and a1 is hanging and the a1 so but I'm
not sure that rule q1 is the best no
fight at Luke FC 1 is the best mm-hmm
but for sure like it's better here what
moves did you consider here for black
actually I I was calculating Bishop c4
takes and b3 was I played in the game
actually couldn't be three will be eight
but since I cure it's not working
because maybe Christie three rugby - you
can take that as a fall yeah maybe F 494
I'm not sure that it's for working maybe
okay yeah and then this pawn is
protected but even here I think like is
fine yeah you have mentioned this Bishop
is still very dumb 1 G 2 so rook e1 I
guess you were surprised by this movie
yeah and I'm happy because I understand
that mm-hmm
here I can't play 94 takes in the
routiers but I see the line that it's
pretty good for black with Bishop c4 and
so it's also better but I think Bishop
c4 is better practical yeah I mean white
can still fight I'm gonna block your
pawn try to defend and just stay solid
yeah but deal move seemed working Queen
yeah fix b3 yes and now if Queen b3
rook fp8 I think important come with F
rook and now okay he don't have coins 3
because I'm Knight f3
yes Knight f3 yeah he can play Queen c2
actually rugby 2 takes
Knight of three takes yeah you have to
take I mean this is still a good trade
yeah and actually the point is that
after Luke if sorry be one mm-hmm
Quincy three and now I want to play
rugby eight uh-huh
so if that's a here would be yeah and
now you can challenge fight on the only
violent then it should yeah so Queen e2
was played yeah which is I think the
best move but I think he missed rugby
eight and after i-494 is very strong I'm
I'm kind of suspect that he missed this
idea yeah did he you think a lot after
night see for no I think actually two
minutes okay so that much okay night see
for but it's kind of logical you have to
pass pawns
yeah rolling down I think he missed a
route before I believe yeah although it
seems fairly logical yeah these pawns
are hard to stop yeah before check see
three Luke D 1 B and C 4 so what's the
difference between clean c5 and
absolutely free to fire fighting is also
winning but I don't identify key 5 I
believe it's C - mm-hmm rooks yuan and
if you create some take stand Queen if I
check so mm-hmm okay you can get murky
although b2 is still kind of yeah I
think it's winning to that okay yeah so
Queen c4 we go to this critical position
rook takes c2 and what did you calculate
here because okay yeah crazy
yeah Quincy 225 what happens in the game
kingi 87 I'm not sure that rule kf8 is
only movie but okay yeah Queenie eight
and yeah the eighth Queen and T
it's very important to take anyone
mm-hmm because otherwise there would be
a hunter chances there the cream would
get extremely pesky yeah it's true so
Queen takes Yvonne was played and then
it's over
and if Queen e1 then Christopher check
because invite a four yeah chose the
fourth and if you take then obviously
checkmate yeah a very nice game yeah
congratulations so you're playing next
I'm not sure but maybe yes sir
so maybe it will be a big match maybe
for first place wow this tactical play
you might just go all the way alright so
is it yeah yeah
so with that congratulations I don't see
you next time
so let's take a look
and nothing much changed actually Kobi
honest on there's around 10 minutes by
Robson's on 25 so actually even the time
situation favors rate here she's not too
surprising as White has this plan that
we already mentioned that Caleb of
doubling and even tripling but the main
issue is for a Kobe on that that's not
the only big threat that he has and that
is G for ideas ah yes so more than one
way yeah challenge the spawn structure
for boy yes it's actually very funny
what the computer suggests it says
Bishop III rook g7 and of course why not
play h6 here and the computer would not
understand the laughter that would come
from this side of the room
of course h6 once you lock up the pawn
structure there's no going back there's
no going back for wait to win this game
he's going to need at least one or two
open files so you need yeah it must be
g4 or something some ways to open it up
but if if this is winning I'm a little
skeptical yeah I I you know obviously
would prefer to have the pony on Age 5
yes so I just find that interesting that
the computer would strongly suggest a
move like h6 which is funny
let's keep it at that mmm but talking
about crazy games I think we should
still take a look at the me huh laughs
yeah fair games of course this was our
key matchup of the day actually uh
between Alexander fear and Victor
mihailovski and it was our key matchup
for a couple reasons but the main thing
was it was such an interesting opening
Alexander if you're actually choosing to
employ the Kings gambit yes
so e4 e5 and it's kind of weird that
everybody including their mom and
grandad plays Knight f3 but da f4
yeah develop your nights behind the
pawns that way to control the squares
even even more thoroughly especially if
you want an open F file you must open it
first yeah when you castle
rooks gonna be on the open file that's
open and be just over there it just
makes sense
so Mena left ski as a season Grand
Master he is played d5 but so we get a
little bit of Kings gambit education
ethics f4 is the main main move and here
Bishop c4 is deaf is your line right
which is supposed to be around even and
complicated it's interesting that we
nature is not the best because black can
get into some trouble after Knight f3 d4
if I get some active play in fact d5 is
the best move here it takes here Knight
c3 and this is a long variation this was
actually played between Simonov and the
u.s. champion gata Kamsky Wow very
interesting um also if you like funny
lines and interesting stories Knight c3
was played by the great garry kasparov
yes I know that guy
against Kuryakin in his Daboo ad rapid
matches in st. Louis Wow so the first
time he played competitive chess I mean
at his return it was I think Queen age
for king he to Queen e7 and after a
crazy game
the game was drawn so I do advise you to
check that out anyways d5 was played
this is the classical way of playing
he takes d5 he takes f4 some people even
fancied efore but obviously taking the
pawn is the main line Knight f3 Knight
f6 Bishop c4 takes Castle Bishop e6 and
this is kind of strange because you
think that white is better with two
central pawns but this pawn is basically
killing the scope of the c1 bishop right
and meanwhile although black doesn't
have Center
pons he has good scores for his pieces
in the Sun yes and that's what really
good piece play for white I mean for
black that is we should be three
actually preparing see for nd for so
what would you play here you would be in
black the black piece and you would be
concerned that c4 and d4 concerned with
c4 and d4 well I don't know III do
really just like developing my pieces
but since I'm so concerned maybe I will
play the move c5 yes the center and
that's the move that me elapsed key
should have played and there was a
Nakamura Tomashevsky game here and this
is decent for black okay but I think my
collapse key wasn't that sure of the ins
and outs of the King's gambit which is
not surprising because understandable I
haven't seen the King's gambit on the
top for like ten years
yeah me as well so Bishop d6 but c4
comes now Knight b6 and d4 which is a
very very pretty move and white does get
some central space now so the main issue
is that you can't take this fun because
you drop a knight actually not that way
excuse me this way yeah and that will
cost you a knight and will thank you for
participating and this tactic exists no
matter which way you capture on c4
actually the midnight sea for it does
work it doesn't oh yes but in this case
you have a d5 I believe d5 actually this
was game night c4 was game d5 doesn't
work because of check and Bishop takes
d5 okay interestingly so rook even was
played by fear all right challenging the
center yes but is not quite winning a
full piece for me yes but it fear is
trying to win the piece actually because
he's threatening rook takes c6 and
Bishop takes c4 and c5 a lot of threats
a lot of others and you know that in
chess usually if there is a double
threat a double attack then you're in
trouble
this is a triple got to avoid the triple
yeah God avoid the triple but there
comes mija left skis 93 solving all of
them impressive stuff so she takes so
it's obviously a normal decision to take
on a three but fear is ambitious and
takes on e6 and goes pawn grabbing with
peen b3 what he's saying is I'm going to
collect all of your pawns not better
it's going to be quite tough for black
to hold on to upon like like III so
White's not wasting his time with
capturing immediate leaves making more
threats Samia Lipsky plays the logical
castles take my pawn so I can develop 97
Queeny for this is all logical rook b8
but maybe rugby is a bit too much like
he could be a little bit more stingy and
defend this guy right because it's a
pawn it deserves defense yeah care for
your pawns everybody yeah and also it's
kind of a perfect outpost potentially to
get it with Knight f6 95 and not that
this position isn't playable but I'm not
sure that black should be worse here
interesting oh yeah I mean he does have
this bishop on d6 yes squares and a very
well defended there's a square for the
knight if black can just put his pieces
where they belong then uh I don't think
I don't think it should be too much
worse I agree with you also this Knight
is a little bit passive so it needs to
find the space somewhere and if it goes
to a3 it really does want to go to c4
yes
so Knight e3 doesn't happen without a
reason so rugby eight was played nine a
three of us played against it Knight f6
but this was a bit too much takes takes
Knight c4 now this pawn on b2 is well
defended and these pieces are starting
to be much much better than blacks
pieces 100% also this e3 pawn is not
gonna survive forever okay so yeah I
guess why had a pretty nice advantage
here yeah Bishop f4 in fact this is
suggested and this is a pretty nice move
you this
night there's a taboo because if you
take I take the h2 on pollen and Queen
takes d5 right so Bishop f4 yeah what
you're saying yeah and if Knight takes D
six I guess there's not up for or
something right yeah or just say well or
just oh yeah you can just capture what
the queen is capture okay so Bishop f4
and this is something that we often make
as beginners like this kind of mistake
that we stick to upon that's going to
fall anyway over-committing yeah so
we're over committed for this pawn and
we miss plays the bishop just for this
fun that that's gonna be lost right so
in fact I think mica left scheme made
his situation much worse that playing
Bishop f4 interesting so g3 saying okay
I would like to see your Bishop on
eighty six because it does nothing there
because I've ski chases the Queen away
first rookie to this is very typical you
double up and even in the grim fault
usually you block the deep on and you
have a night on these seven blocking it
right and eventually this just Falls
also notice sooner or later I'm gonna
play Knight ce-5 and then you really
won't have any protection for that pawn
queen d5 Knight c5 is predicted takes
takes will be six looks serum so this is
pretty good for right especially because
this Bishop is completely out of play
because it's staring at a pawn that will
never move also these pawns are pretty
weak what we learn about pawn Islands
what about pylons so we usually want to
have all our pawns in a block right and
you can see that black has like at least
four pawn on islands yeah of course you
know the e pawns isolated the C pawn in
the a pawn none of these pawns can
defend each other yes this is the
meaning of having too many pawn islands
yes yeah they might be a good vacation
spots yes it they don't make for very
safe homes yeah those are pretty unsafe
kingi eight night fe5 and this is what I
was talking about that stranger danger
this rook will hop and tried to eat that
pawn as soon as a knight will come back
obviously that's not possible right now
because that would drop a knight but in
the near future that is going to happen
so a 6 B 4 G's 95 83 and black was
uncertain of what's going on he should
have waited around rook d7 or something
but instead play g6 which makes sense he
wants to bring the bishop back but then
tragedy struck yes of course there's a
tactic here yes so 97 it seems like
nothing big is going on but after
attacking a rock just attacking a rope
but after rugby 7 it's gonna be over yet
there's of course the killer move rook
c5 attacking the knight which is
actually indefensible and then and even
if you would go rugby five needs say
haha view still thank you yes and then
of course the notorious triple attack
and family fork strikes again
strikes again and again and again so
Bishop g7 was displayed but that's kind
of admitting that it's over right just
giving up the exchange you know the rest
was just white converting a very nice
game so he just brought the king as a
new form of locating that pawn and after
that it's just completely over as all of
the pawns are falling after rook c6 yeah
brought the King to a nice central
square it's perfectly safe there
defending the D pawn as well as the
night and now White's pieces are just
better than dominating and after this
why just swooped all the pieces up and
me how that ski decided that this was
enough enough was enough
yes threw in the towel here so very
interesting game
Alexander figures showing some good
understanding of the King's gambit
his victim malevsky may be under
estimating the c4d for idea probably
underestimate at c4 d4 and also I think
he had good chances in the after the
opening so in the middle game right but
I think he didn't really sense the
danger and actually I think Bishop f4
Bishop h6 was the cause yeah this this
awkward decision to really hold on to
you three when in fact sometimes you
just have to let go
that's stuff even in life yeah well with
the key matchups out of the way I guess
we can go we can go ahead and check out
any game that you like so the leader
Yasser Quezada just drew yes he that
manga Patricia drew his game and that
does set up the big match Yasser Quezada
vs hawk Obiang yeah absolutely so on his
game so that'll be the the big thing to
look out for tomorrow of course jacobian
one of the the chasers in the B group he
moves to +1 in the tournament after his
big one today also chasing yes sir is
actually Dennis Kendrick who is also on
+1 and with a win today he would move to
+2 overall yeah so let's take a look at
that ya know receive the two players
working hard at the board Dennis with a
very interesting hoody choice today yes
a very stylish perfect choice it's a
very pretty sunny day
actually it was even nicer yesterday
yeah 100%
- I understand that it was time to take
out the purple take out the purple what
is what does that mean I don't know it's
a new phrase alright and it took out the
purple today yep we took out the purple
oh how that works out for them so
Gregorian says which would be one that a
you might want to start pushing this
spawn but I doubled on the seventh and
it's usually no good news scary for a
scary but in fact objectively it still
might be equal as I think maybe here and
after that you give infinite amount of
checks
now not that you can't lose this if you
don't pay attention right check I check
you if you go here oops
mate yes but probably important for
black not to step to the h8 square
though yeah because you don't want to
give up this H pawn with check yes and
after King f8 white does not have time
to capture on h7 making a check mating
threat because black would actually
queen with check himself so not not
enough time for for white to really make
any progress so I will make that
incredible prediction of this game
ending in a draw
sure is there any way for the the
players to keep the game going from this
current position here absolutely not
absolutely not
alright well looking like a draw for -
yes that it looks all the Dennises will
agree that after rugby 7 it's most
likely a drama yeah I'm on board with
that as well Who am I to disagree with
the grandmasters well what else is going
on in the a group then so the early
leader received or a badly just drove it
Alex Thunderman oh yes so that's a very
interesting game did you want to check
that one out um I'm still checking at
the live games ok and let's take another
look again not he match the Robson game
yeah as any progress been made it seems
is the environment a very committal
choice yes so rook h2 was played vogue
g7 and strange as it might seem Robson
didn't play h6 outrageous very strange
maybe ray wants to win the game actually
Wow like it's unbelievable alright King
G - lets play G takes rook F H 1 and G
takes h5 might seem like strange but I
think what a COPI on wants is to get a
little bit more space for a little bit
of more breathing space for the pieces
yeah understandable and there's a
certain psychological aspect to it where
it's like alright fine
we're opening up the Kings side but it's
gonna be on my terms yeah I get to
choose I'll take your pollen age 5 not
get to capture me yeah so Bishop g6 yeah
that's a good point sometimes you want
to demonstrate
that I'm in control of the situation
even if the truths is somewhere down
there around somewhere else yes
so Bishop h5 so we should page 5 is an
idea you can't capture the many ways but
in fact you don't have to rush and often
in these close up positions it's
something to consider to put your king
into safety first
yeah yes why not I make like seven moves
in a row but what are you going to do
about it yeah I don't know maybe black
has to try some way to get those last
two major pieces to the Kings side but
there's really it's not enough room for
all the pieces yeah so probably a way to
do that let's say King f1r okay seven to
bring this rook over play Knight c8 I
just want to demonstrate this and recap
seven right and it still makes sense to
go here because on b2 there's absolutely
no danger of anything ever happening
right yeah this this Queen side
structures is locked up for good
yeah so that's why it's often the case
that black would do the same and hope
that his King would be safe on b8 as
well
yeah understandable and then I guess
eventually once everything is perfectly
set ray is going to capture on h5 and
try to break through along this age file
so Bishop h5 seems like one of the best
moves because you can't really take as
if the knight enters on f6 it's over of
course basically game over because this
Knight is just a monster and in the poor
tuned moment I just played g4 and this
must be losing but then the problem is
if you don't take h5 once again at the
right moment white will capture on g6
and to keep the night out you might be
tempted to play H takes but then there
are these invasion squares yeah white on
both h6 and AJ yeah and I hear that
we're going to soon have the hero of the
King's gambit yes of course under fear
so while you wrap up some analysis here
maybe you can reintroduce that for your
game okay I will take a step out of the
studio once again and while we get
Alexander fear in to talk about his eyes
so and as predicted the Dennises were
right it's a draw so it was okay to
bring your purple in any case let's see
a more bloody game that we just went
through the good old Kings gambit
so here eat xf4 Knight f3 is the old
line d5 would actually transpose back to
the game played between Alexander fear
and me galovski but aged 6 is kind of
the annoying move and g5 and to be
completely honest I do not believe that
black equalizes even if you do it with
d6 d4 g5 I'm still skeptical and in fact
black doesn't really want to go g4 he
mostly wants to go h6 Bishop g7 and I'm
not sure there's enough play here but we
have Alexander here here whom I really
hope they'll disagree with me and say
that this is just busted for black well
actually in this position was really
considered to go h4 yeah v f7 yeah yeah
now H was actually pretty good here and
63 not h3 Wow nice old stuff and and
this is check on a track and attack also
I'm curious about your opinion about the
h6 line h6 bit 3 is good be pleased it
and then you put the fishpond be to be 2
and you get this long castle kind of
play alright so after all the Kings game
it is winning left for d5 were you
expecting d5 from me elapsed key usually
he goes Bishop c5 actually
more on the Clannad mm-hmm but he had
one game with the fire mm-hmm
so d5 was played Bishop c5 as far as I
know this is fairly decent for white
so yeah it's likable yeah it's kind of
occasion you have some pre initial when
I was young it was playing with native
three to six before oh nice basically a
Kings gambit version of the events
gambit
there's a nice mix yeah I love it it
takes then c3 and then I guess d4 you
know so let's go back to d5 takes takes
Knight f3
did he play these moves fairly fast who
he was thinking of it okay oh so he was
taking his time yeah 95 Castle should be
six here and I think Bishop d6 is not
that great well c5 is in my line here
and then it usually goes to four takes
takes and Bishop c5 I take away the
night Bishop c5 mm-hm and I mean you
definitely have strong pressure yeah go
Qing Yi Shuang I don't have some point
I'll get this pawn back mm-hmm yeah look
it's also fun black is also fine there I
heard about bortnik and it ended in a
draw yes port Nick sweats was a drop so
what were you saying no bishop this X I
didn't know so I start to think here but
I knew that this idea with sacrificing
the c4 pound exists but I talking
usually with the bishop on e7 I was not
sure what was the difference yeah
so c4 before but this felt very very
good thing yeah night c4 rook e1
what were you calculating here was rook
e1 your first and only choice well I
thought this might not work
and there are Queen Ichiro's mm-hmm but
this is not is not so bad
yet the fact bishops working each one
and then he takes with something on the
5 and
I'm not sure about it but I had here
there may be some attack on these
because this night is a little bit loose
that's the main problem and also we can
finally get that Bishop out from c1 and
if you ever played the King's gambit you
know the hell when deceitfulness stuck
there forever
yeah so I went more than solid like a
rookie why we it's still kind of strong
as I talked with Caleb this is a triple
threat
so Knight e3 was just right there to
survive them I thought I would get some
bounce back
so did you consider taking on e3 yeah
but I thought that if I take both pawns
on me Black is fine because so I had to
try to monetize yeah
but I knew that they could be slightly
blue because truly it was very
interesting 97 queenie for so here he
says that t5 looks quite interesting
d5 yeah because he was thinking like 40
minutes on the position I didn't know
what for me Brooke me it was like
supernatural yeah he said that you're
thinking if I have takes Knight takes
Knight takes Queen f6 Oh some
checkmating stuff yeah if I even not f3
queen [ __ ] oh nice war in d2 and engage
hate and he's have rook f3 and queen of
Chu coming yeah I drew carey's brutal so
I should go something else so something
I Knight c3 yeah and then I have 95
ideas yeah positions to yet complicated
interesting so if I've might have been a
better choice and should this this
happen to many of us like you think for
40 minutes at the critical move plays
something else and regret it
yeah actually we were considering rook
e8 here maybe it's just to go get the
knight on d5 it's also very normal but
okay rook b8 is a fine move and I like
93 because if b3 I have some problems
with the diagonal
even if you play c5 it's improved
version yeah that this is completely in
the way so 93 I want to go to Safari
then that's really well I'm not and if
he takes on a three I get rid of this
Bishop yes yeah and now all of these
phones are super weak it's interesting
this kind of reminds me of the Queens
gambit accepted within four lines Knight
f6 takes Knight c4 it was good that
positions he still was too okay but he
had like one minute sir one minute
Wow what was your turn count one of our
turns
well now it's Wendy you're reaching the
heights of nap on the idea
so Bishop f4 and I said fell to Bishop
f4 is just it's miss placing this Bishop
it's logical but it's miss placing it
mm-hmm but no but this it depends upon
no that's true g3 Bishop H okay now here
realize that okay I can try to attack
but the peels defending like he has a
lot of pieces there so I thought the
endgame would be really Pleasant so
let's fast forward to about positional
Kings gambit yeah the position yes and
actually you're just positionally so
much better yeah so here you just you
have a great position I guess you were
surprised to see g6 yeah actually I was
waiting to see what he was gonna do okay
okay so actually not that easy to come
up with a construction and okay I'm
bringing my King know like you can go to
g3 of three four in some lines and then
d3 yeah and it's not clear what he's
doing now yeah and I mean you're just
dominating it's very hard to move but
after g6 this night these sound is just
overdone then it's over after this one
this is just winning and I have after
basically Bishop g7 Knight takes b6
it was basically over yeah I can bring
the king and at some point I'm gonna
activate the rose and a very nice win
yeah it's good to see the return of the
King's gambit once in a while you know
when people are desperate yeah yeah
these kind of things happen that's
protections for desperate times I wanted
to go on a top 7 to see if I
rookie five mate well that'd be super
cute checkmate and defend it let it go
but anyways it's still winning and after
this and then I have worked this 7mate
coming yeah this one coming
which is also pretty cool it's a very
nice win yeah thank you thank you
who are you playing next there is not
many people you might be able to even
more chances to yeah there are many more
gambits to try many more give it a try
yes all right so the nice Kings gambit
win thank you and hope you keep up the
good spirit thank you thank you three
games left and let's take a look what's
still going on let's go back to the
Akopian game it's kind of heating up
it's predicted what was planning to take
the h5 pawn and did after some
preparation like Queen d1 Bishop takes
h5 and the Cobian even though down to a
minute and 57 seconds he still finds the
best possible maneuver of getting the
King out of the danger zone alright so
yeah bara is packing up and leaving yeah
packing up and leaving but maybe he's
he's a bit too late right I don't think
white rooks are coming in quite quickly
yeah and what's that move that registed
they just played Bishop f3 okay so he's
choosing not yet to capture on June 6 so
at this moment we kind of suspect that
there could be only two results right
yeah don't ever see black winning this
game but surely you're not about to
suggest that well I'm going to suggest
something though okay so Bishop f3 might
if white has a good plan of doubling
say winning something right or playing
on the h-file it's still a game for two
okay I win or a draw but if someone dare
touch the Jeep on them push it one
square forward right it can suddenly
turn into anyone's game
well yeah that seems like it would be a
mistake for white because this F 5
square is something that a know what the
Black Knight would love to use in a
black Bishop but also of course be
opened up and even though this is kind
of unreasonable because Bishop efore is
pretty strong immediately right
but even if I will play like some moves
and still G for blacks pieces come alive
even if I give up the e6 pawn it's not a
big deal and suddenly every black pieces
live writes because they were just
waiting for the sign Oh G for showing up
yeah I'm expecting rise just gonna play
a bit more simply you know just triple
on the H follow maybe put a rook on h6
and generate some threats that way yes
so Queen e2 was played and possibly this
will be a game for two results but if
Robson might feel that he wants to win
this game anyways is going to be the g4
move but then it's going to be anyone's
game
alright that'll be interesting to watch
we'll have to keep an eye out for that
other than that we haven't taken a look
at so many games in the a group how is
Mel kuhnian smearin doing I think that's
the last game that we haven't looked at
yet yep so if my pawn count is correct
its equal right I agree
1 2 3 3 2 3 wait no ok yeah yeah yeah
it's true it checks out
[Music]
and let's say I defend the pawn yeah if
anything uh
yeah maybe here I would prefer wait
I could start hassling you and this
would be dangerous because it's not
bishop is dominated by this knight and
that would be not great sure you
definitely don't want to run into such
quite quite such a terrible passivity
there yeah but I'm gonna like naturally
defend this actually there's this very
nice active defense
yeah active defensive oh you take it but
I have a Bishop d6 I can check but this
pawn and this Knight is double attacked
so more than likely I will have just
enough either if you defend it I move up
with my king and this is kind of this
typical Marshall kind of compensation
I have active peace play with this
active rook and Bishop well even though
I'm down a pawn you can't really do
anything to me all right well while
these games keep going on I think in
just a moment here we're gonna take a
quick look at a special offer from Ryan
Chester and go on a quick short little
break anything interesting to say before
we leave Dennis no I think we're ready
too all right it's a look of course
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues what about after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us and you guys
know I can't play this right st. Loup is
always exploring that we get your
autograph
you have course I think it's pretty cool
that you love chess so much we love
chess too I draw a school chess program
and got to meet a real-life Grandmaster
I got this big one time I put a police
captain after school and check my name
in 27 moves Wow I should be asking for
your autograph
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org be surprised be
intrigued be delighted the World Chess
Hall of Fame in st. Louis is nothing
you'd expect and everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
professional Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion for those of you who are
new to chess it might look like ba3 is
an illegal move here because white
masters pawn to square is not one but it
still is something we call all pass on
and you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I'd
let say play King in seven games e2 and
now try because I'll play for against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think he practiced I know Oh
Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
Church to work like this I don't think
it does well maybe it does well that's
me regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of my quality of life has
just gone downhill tremendously because
I'm actually sharing the office with the
guy
[Music]
you
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck a golden
opportunity indeed make sure you get
your golden tickets before it's too late
once again they are drawing those on
September 30th talking about drawing
yeah well uh Bortnick and spirits drew
their games so let's take a look at that
absolutely 3:45 very standard and here
did white play the correct first move
nope no big mistake he played Bishop c4
not even challenging the e5 s Alexander
fear pointed out f4 white his way in so
Bishop c4 but forgivable mistake
developing his piece yeah he pleased
them of the piece Knight f6 defended the
pawn with d3 this is all standard stuff
c6 black is actually taking advantage
that the e5 pawn doesn't need defense so
he does not need to play knight c6 first
so he can build a center with d5 and a
385 Bishop b3 check it's interesting to
mention that this is not both Nick's
first game playing this line he I think
faced a5 in the perceived reveille game
where he was again white right so Bishop
b4 check was played Bishop d2 takes
Queen takes d2 a5 a4 and interestingly
this is a big favorite of the Chinese
players especially the super talent
varies with the the white pieces of the
black the white pieces interesting so
why does white go for this line where
black gets some central pressure going
on where you
to advance very quickly so white is
trying to put pressure on the center and
if D takes e4 then fight actually has
not have seven ideas looked except 7d
take c4 and vent two pawns for the
eventual two pieces this is a decent try
for an advantage note that you have to
take take and if you move the knight I
can take this eventually and have two
pawns and yeah the previously Anibal
position and possibly an advantage here
yeah there's something like this we're
dead white can pay for play for an
advantage but spirits knows his stuff he
castles he takes the 5c takes Knight
takes e5 so this was practically a pawn
sacrifice right but if they're just a
little bit familiar with the marshal we
know that a bishop on beats me staring
at the d5 pawn never means that you're
going to win the game yes understandable
all right with that extra pawn sitting
on c2 tough to imagine it it generates
much the four Queen b6 note that sweets
is immediately putting pressure not
waiting for white to actually develop
his pieces finding counter play takes
Knight e4 and the counter play is
getting really real because Bishop a6
will also come to the tempie and the d4
pawn is starting to get a bit
loosey-goosey we need three Bishop a6
rook e1 before probably thinking of
maybe even taking because even though
here you could be up upon but honestly
with this structure it's less structure
the LightSquared bishop is never gonna
see daylight again unless white where to
play something like c4 yes but then the
bishops might get traded
yes and also if push comes to shove rook
fe fe 8 is also fine
absolutely so that three was played
Brooke 88 was the response which is very
nice pointing out that your rook is not
defended in for some serious sake I'll
take everything so 92 had to be played
between D 2 F 2 XE 4 between before he 5
f6 and again the main issue this guy is
not playing it staring at a brick wall
a terrible piece called c6 d5 and if
this were to be on f3 we would be
celebrating today but instead you know
you have this black bishop on e6 cutting
through the position eyeing a e 2 and
especially the F 1 square yeah I got
very difficult for what to do a d1 was
played takes takes rook air-five and the
main issue is for white that even though
you're up a pawn you don't have a
constructive plan and so it's not
surprising that the game soon will end
in a draw as Y doesn't really have a
coherent plan Bishop c4 takes d4 and the
game is soon fizzling out to a draw
yeah the rooks not not much of an
advantage here yes especially with this
deep on yeah white will have to look out
for they're going to have to take a more
defensive setup yeah rather than trying
to any diamonds
so the only way to be aggressive is to
attack the g7 phone but even if you win
that I have a passed pawn you can't
really get rid of that one so the game
will likely end in a draw anyways right
so that's why the players just agreed in
a draw yeah pretty relevant stuff for
the a group of course daro and bortnik
two of the players hoping to make a
little bit more progress towards the
leaders that are still sitting on 50%
but on popular demand we heard that
people might want to see desert yes I'm
on Hambleton game and they do have a
somewhat interesting position right now
for the MoMA
it looks as though White has more Queens
than black but yeah black seems to be
running out of Queens yes you only get
the one you only get two is one good to
make use of it while you can still can't
but if you want to collect you should
collect some more so it seems they did
collect an extra queen
yeah but an exchange now a Mon actually
has a rookie tonight and one or two
pawns as well yeah so it's not that
black is completely lost because this
night on c5 gives some stability to the
position very important piece on the
downside let's talk about islands again
yes so how many weak pawns does black
have Oh a lot yes I don't know if I can
count that far I like my math skills
okay
b6 d6 soon to be f5 if white were to
capture their g6 you could qualify as
well and if he takes F does happen then
h5 I think would be weak as well so 5 is
the number yes oh and God forbid the b6
pawn moves then a5 is weak oh no that's
too many notice so let's stick with 5
pawn islands yeah I don't know it's like
every part of blacks camp is kind of
suspect 2 to attack yeah mix ideas of
like a fortress
and really seem a little bit more
far-fetched yes on the other hand Aman's
rooks are glorious it's true and where
White's to go nuts
you could even win with them of course
but obviously this is a grandmaster
tournament so dziak will not give away
his queen for just a single ruckus well
no but there is this problem of the
white king as well yes like if white
goes a little bit crazy ever then maybe
these works will infiltrate and at least
generate some threats perpetual if not
more so the only thing going for a mon
here is f takes e4 on being on the cards
right but it's just a pawn and this King
still can safely be
stations on h3 yeah are there immediate
problems for black here so rook c8 was
playing yeah I don't think black it has
the option to block with rook e8 because
they would run into this problem where
you could take and take on f5 and this
is completely losing yeah of course
so instead you have to move your king if
you go to somewhere like h7 I'd be
slightly concerned about moves like
Queen c3 or Queen B - I'm going up this
h8 square and this is deadly so I guess
this leaves the black with maybe only
one option and that's to play king f7
but that's what a mom played it looks a
bit shaky to me there's these
dark-squared problems yeah why it is
really threatening to infiltrate before
black can find some kind of life and in
fact that's probably the best idea to
start infiltrating and so Queen d2 what
can black even do well if you sit around
this is just over yeah a hundred percent
probably is just so you must take okay
so the question is you could give a
check you could go Queen eight six maybe
I think I'll just play Queen age six
okay I'd say that for argument's sake if
I take okay I wanted to play King h3 and
hope I could hide on this square until
the end of time hopefully the end of
time coming when your checkmated yes so
I assume you want to go here ah yeah I
was thinking with the Queen but uh we
can play your move as well that's true
so you get maybe I get more stylistic
points alright so but probably no
stylistic points needed because the
knight was 97
we're from the rook and the Queen and
then I guess I don't really have much
here I can give a few checks but maybe I
even know none of those yeah but if
anyone would ask me on the street which
side I would want to play without
hesitation I'll go white yeah I tend to
agree oh you know I feel like I've
played this quite poorly for white here
in this this F pawn might cause some
problem yeah it might cause some
problems but I said rather be white
anyways King f7 and Queen C ball
misplayed
say the good news for black is it seems
as though if you know weight isn't quite
mess enough to just forget about
everything and try to check me yeah why
it does have to respond a little bit at
least to some of blacks threats the bad
news is if white is super precise I
don't see black lasting long yeah it's a
lot easier to be precise here with white
and yes with black yeah black makes one
mess up then all of a sudden he's dead
boss yeah whereas white can mess
something up and oh okay maybe now it's
supposed to be a draw but flexible has
to play accurately like mess up again
and it's still supposed to be a draw
where is one slip up from black and I
need to lower that just absolutely
ginger so this still does the disasters
for Aman who is kind of having a rough
tournament as far as I know yeah this
definitely one of one of his worst
performances that I've seen him play out
but uh you know just got to keep on
playing there's three more cholitas
happen like I've seen even on the
highest of the high levels like Anand
floundering on the button in like big
tournaments and he still came back
strong so I wouldn't write off a mom
this is just an uncharacteristically bad
tournament for him yeah I don't know if
it's comforting or depressing that you
can get to be as good as at chess as a
player like a Mont Hambleton and then
still every once in a while a tournament
just comes up or it's like used it just
says that how tough it is to play
against such good opposition yeah if
you're not in your tapas of forms I
definitely agree
so with that so it seems as though the
players in the Ray Robson bar Cobian
game are following your advice slightly
yes having brought both of their kings
over this queenside probably it's not
just me who's interested in vacations
but the black and white King as well yes
going on a day trip yes so inside this
King will be going to be seven and the
white King will be a day trip
/ to be to summon a driver
yes Sunday driver wonderful weekend in
st. Louis 97 row bg8 okay six and I'm
not sure what they do but today it seems
that they are just shuffling a lot yeah
you know of course they did just hit
move 40 so they just got some extra time
so maybe now we'll find some meaningful
shuffling yes the only issue here with
white is if you'd consider taking let's
say here H takes oh no no no no H takes
okay with this guy so this seems like
the Persian Greek war there's just not
enough space to push on through as the
Persians never did break through the
Greek fortress okay and perhaps white is
in need of a Trojan horse then in order
to correct enough the position correct I
know White's idea after this last move
Queen g2 he's kind of telegraphing that
he might be considering to put his horse
onto this d5 square and rip open the
black that's a gift a gift that you do
not want to take okay all right so for
example you take Steve Bishop takes D
Knight takes Queen takes and now white
would have a couple connected passers in
exchange for the full piece but I'm not
totally convinced yeah this is the
fortunately for white black will have
enough moves to blockade all those pawns
yeah so the situation where if white
could play like this and give away the
dark squared bishop instead then maybe
there's something to it but with black
having the light squared bishop it's
very easy to set up a blockade yeah
probably this would turn into a Greek
tragedy is and not the end of the Troy
and war well so that's why you play King
b2 but
so there's a high chance that this game
is going to be a draw but as I mentioned
before g4 might make the position
double-edged interests and I think
Robson might consider playing that if he
really wants to win the game but also I
agree with Caleb that I this wouldn't be
the first game where I see 40 move more
moves played and then Knight takes d5
yeah so all these two to get a Trojan
horse in mind with with the white pieces
you know I can imagine getting a little
bit frustrated where it's like you have
all this extra space you can pile up all
of your pieces over here but it seems as
though your opponent just just has
enough pieces and responds yes it's
tough to break through so probably this
will be a three-way game after a
potential G for either now or later but
note that the screen is not too far from
building a battery and that's not just
dangerous
it could even be mate yeah black does in
fact still have the space advantage on
the Queen yet so if your things open up
on the Kings side and black can really
invade then I think the white King is
actually probably in more danger than
the black yes
so g4 might open up the game again and I
wouldn't be a hundred percent sure I
would know the result of the game all
right so this Miriam it seems as though
we we do have a result there yeah
actually I believe our internal
community Leah smear and have agreed to
a draw which is of course what we were
expecting from that game and you're just
just another equal endgame yes and we
have only one game left but you had that
one game left in the a group and one
game left in the B group and it looks
actually as though a lot of progress has
been made in that game between them on
Hamilton and Stevens Erick let's take a
look at without one pair of rooks being
traded off and white invading with the
Queen so zerk unfortunately to Hambleton
fans is being really precise obviously
you can't go and run for it because I
made you
to have to play we have six but bamboo
calf 8 it is can defend this rook
anymore
takes the meeting problem is I'm gonna
take this pawn with a check or the g6
bottom of the check you have doing
crawling with check
unfortunately so let's say here takes
seems reason here I'd take this one was
why not
mm-hmm and this still looks awful not
that you can't potentially if you can do
some magic and put this rope on e6 okay
maybe fortress give it a mover - yeah
maybe black can come up with something
but it's it's tough to find your time so
if you could somehow get your work to e6
you can build a fortress but I heard
like proponents of anti anti fortress
people namely Magnus Carlsen saying yes
the term exists but the whole thing
doesn't rights of course Magnus does not
believe in for Tricia no forces and you
can imagine here even if black did
somehow put this rook on e6 there's
still paths for the White King that kind
of invade and that's going to be a big
problem for black in the future also the
other issue is I might walk my King up
yeah a g4 let me even do that oh I can't
because it's not my turn
g4 takes takes dishes I'm going to go to
g5 yeah there's this path is and then
after the King gets to g5 if a check is
ever given to the black king
yeah and the white king can come if I
connects ever get to the seventh rank
it's going to be over it's looking a lot
like checkmate yes or Christmas um
depends on who you are yeah its defense
who you are but in any case this looks
like a field trip to Zurich and not much
fun for Amon yeah
so are there any results that we did not
actually take a glance at he did not
take a look at the perceived the
Lenderman perceived rebellion so let's
do that okay that game of course ended
in a draw
yeah and yet Linderman coming off of a
tough game yesterday where it looked as
though he didn't achieve too much of the
opening with the white pieces but he was
never really in danger if he wanted to
hold never in danger and then chose to
make things a little bit interesting and
it kind of backfired on him yeah that's
how ray Robson got his body
Nerys great nation final so no risk no
champagne me too
okay you too and I said yeah yes it up
we have an A in English yep this is the
classical Hedgehog it would be with c5
but the Rabbi Levin for Bishop e7
transposing back to this classical line
rook e1 is stem kramnik move preparing
efore without actually telling you if
I'm going to play Knight c3 or not not a
six waiting for Knight c3 then you could
at least pin yeah pretty phonetic stuff
a3 saying nope I want to play Knight c3
and then e4 but then the sieve says I
haven't seen enough benoni in this
tournament c5 the five takes Knight H
494 this is a typical way of getting the
benoni structure right there is like a
threat of pushing the pawn and being a
pawn up yeah there is this difference
here in the structure where the
LightSquared bishop or black ends up on
b7 looking at the center which there's
some cases where that's advantageous but
there are also other times where it ends
up being rather stunted on yeah seven so
see things need five wanting to take
that night but the seif wants to take
the other night okay
Bishop f6 obviously this is a no-no cuz
I'll take you Knight c3 g6 and
la Benoni okay 97 Queen d3 and now did I
belly admits that if we could ever go
back with pawns in chess be preferred to
unmoved this g6 phone and put it back to
g7 and just play h6
ah yes because this is way more stable
than the g6 h7 but you can't have a
benoni without it normally oh yeah
understandable so we're keen difference
yeah key differences so rook t1 rook e8
Queen c2 b5 and as we already talked
with Jaco bein around Jaco bein when you
see b5 coming in the Benoni that does
not mean that things are going bad for
black yeah definitely
black achieving some some necessary
breaks yeah but you not not to say that
White's position is bad it's not bad but
blacks positions not worse anymore okay
so Bishop g2 and I think Lenderman kind
of I realized that it's time to pull the
brakes a little bit
so he's preparing Knight e4 to attack
the d6 and the f6 the d6 pawn and the f6
Bishop so before 94 Bishop e5 and lots
of lots of exchanges happen Bishop d5
Knight c4 rook h5
okay so white has lost the D pawn yeah
that's a very often in bananas
even if the whites deep hunt falls that
actually leaves the d6 pawn a little bit
more susceptible to attack so definitely
nothing not too much to worry about here
for wait yes
rook h5 was actually a very nice move by
the safe as he might hope for Queen d7
Queen h3 ideas but unfortunately for him
Lenderman is good at liquidating here
and even though white is like a slight
Pole because these pieces are slightly
better than blacks it's not enough for
an advantage
and the draw is the most likely results
might be six takes Queenie seven broke
the three of the eight basically black
has enough pressure to neutralize by its
initiative and and that's exactly what
happened inside five takes and after
these exchanges the players agreed to a
draw as Queenie for Queen B one that
would be a perpetual joy Depardieu
screen takes B to F you just want to
take the pawn definitely a draw and the
more interesting side though yeah both
players kind of navigating their ideas
and reaching the natural conclusion of
chess chess is a draw unless you play
the Kings gambit yes well as we we are
running a little bit short on time here
but I did want to take another look at
this rate Robson game because he has
actually played g4 I told you break I
told you that you can trust me trying
the last possible chance that makes the
game interesting and he decided now was
the time so of course
Varis actually been thinking about this
move for quite a while yeah which is
understandable this is a this is a
pretty key moment so what's going on if
Mike just captures this is the most
natural de Bishop g4 it kind of feels
the normal move yes we want to be on de
sick open up this diagonal put more
pressure if Knight f5 then I think it's
time to bring in the Trojan horse yes
boom finally finally an active work
finally the Trojans fall as everything's
falling as well so night of five not a
possibility here not a possibility
but that's kind of annoying does he
really want to block that youth and even
if you go here I might just consider
this one and this battery might prove
deadly
even if you would move the bishop I
still have one A two three four
attackers that might just outnumber you
definitely so maybe black should not be
capturing this but yeah probably on
second thought it should not be captured
so what happens if black just sits and
plays
I'd say in d7 yeah yeah it's not there's
a big difference if we would take I
think that's something not really on the
best of ideas maybe Knight takes f5
hitting the rook yeah it's not the most
comfortable way for white to uh to
continue robably so if you like these
sacrifices it's time for us to go crazy
I do like going crazy
yeah maybe no there's actually going to
be some kind of attack on the on the
black can let's say what happens if it
takes I assume we check yes definitely
need to create the board and stuff like
I don't know as Rick takes f5 too much
to do
okay let's do it but I think that's a
bit dangerous because you would bring my
queen to checkmate you as we talked
before I do not like getting checkmated
but Knight f6 looks like an idea yeah
absolutely
bringing in the family fork and let's
say rock h2 and as some popular band
would say we would start rollin rollin
rollin yes and I don't think that you
should be shocked that this is pretty
nice for white yeah this is a definitely
shaping up to be one of the games of the
tournament yeah of course these players
are going to need a lot of time to
figure this one out
and unfortunately we are coming to the
close of our show so why don't we hear
one last time from Ryan Chester with
another special offer on the Golden
Tickets
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
chess club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck all right very
exciting off for him Ryan Chester I can
hardly contain my excitement for this
raffle coming up but okay Denish most of
the games have finished of this kirei
robson game of course is going to go
along into the night we believe but why
don't we take a look at the standings
and see where we set after six rounds in
the fall chess classic so of course ray
robsons games still in progress against
vara Cobain we're not expecting him to
lose this game but honestly almost
anything could happen almost anything
could happen and have a watchful eye on
this game because fire Burks might
happen
definitely chasing him is jordan von
forest with three and a half points and
after him are a myriad of players all
with the 50% score of 3 out of 6 and
Alexander Linderman received air by Lee
Darrow's routes and Courant mulku Mian
and possibly Bart if he manages to draw
or even somehow win this game yeah and
how about the B group where do we stand
there yeah circus Otto Perez drew his
game today bringing his score to an
astounding 5 out of 6
Injection Bulli AK former leader of
groupie of course he started with three
wins then only managed to follow that up
with two draws and today he actually
falls to the power of alexander fears oh
actually to a romhack o bein in a very
display quezada next round
so it's going to be a big match so it's
looking as though jack is falling off a
bit from his early start
yes and of course following them is
Dennis CAD rich and a romhack Obion both
on three and a half a lot of players to
look out for in this
a group as we round into the final third
of this this tournament well then what
are you expecting - for tomorrow what
should we be what should we be looking
out for I'm kind of expecting a big
battle between Quezada and Huckabee on
yeah on the other hand I will be very
interested of what may Robson will do
next round as well yes
Robbie's packing fire he's been winning
game after game and there's a lot
hanging in this one so yeah a lot
probably if he wins this game he could
go five in a row
yeah insane um which would be astounding
but I think it's still up in the air but
will happen in this one all right well
I'd be a big definitely recommend
staying tuned at us chest champs calm if
you want if you would like to see the
conclusion of this round see what
happens in those final two games still
going on I know I'm gonna be keeping an
eye on Ray Robson's game you two
expecting him to be here well into the
evening with a position like this as
always my name's Caleb Denby I'm joined
by the wonderful Grandmaster - Boros and
we would like to thank you for watching
for joining us today be sure to join us
tomorrow for round 7 coverage and once
again
thank you for watching our coverage of
the 2019 ball chess classic be there
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you